and what I hope people will get from
this discussion
is that a topic that probably most
people thought they had no interest in
turns out to have a thousand fascinating
and even if you're not fascinated by
them important facets right right
um right you know fire suppression is
not a small matter here in the west this
is a serious issue that we deal with the
smoke that comes off these fires even
when the fires are remote the
degradation and the quality of life you
know as a result of
a failure to understand equilibria with
respect to um
the natural process of fire that you
know removes the fuel at a particular
rate where you know we had what a
hundred years of fire suppression that
resulted in a huge buildup of fuel so
that when the fires burn they decimate
the landscape right that's a failure to
understand equilibria and what I learned
from you is that actually beavers are
also uh an important factor in
suppressing Fire by
adjusting the way water flows through
these ecosystems so you know
are you interested in fire suppression
in the west well if you live in the west
you better be right because you're going
to be breathing the consequences
otherwise or driven out of your home or
whatever so so anything more to say
about um beavers and Fire
uh I had the experience of um
responding sorry volunteer with search
and rescue and I responded to a fire I
guess it's two years ago now that burnt
two of the nearby towns down more or
less Phoenix and talent and there's a
green way that connects all of these
towns in the Rogue Valley
um you know a really great thing right
somebody said hey we want a Greenway
let's buffer the creek let's give it a
lot of room let's put a bike path in
yeah I believe I've ridden repeatedly
down there when I went when Heather uh
got me a bike building Course in Ashland
yes yeah of course um I used to ride
that Greenway all the time yeah before
the fire before the fire go ahead what
happened yeah so so we had some intense
wins and somebody started a little fire
that became a big fire
um that Greenway which to our human
perspective looked like verdant healthy
habitat acted like a wick and it it drew
fire
through two cities
wow you know when we imagine Fire coming
in from the hills and like time to
escape this way but no this was it never
even went into the hills it drew fire
through these cities because the stream
had collapsed down into a ditch the
water was unavailable it was down there
right and people got used to that it's
like a creek you know something you look
down on right and and even in that
context where we had a really wide space
where people hadn't actually built close
to it the fact that the creek was
collapsed meant that
plants that can take advantage of this
novel Niche like Blackberry had fully
colonized this entire riparian area
right if if there was water that was all
over the place and there was this messy
braided marshy thing you know black boy
don't do well in that right and the
native plants that were lamenting the
loss of would be doing excellently well
because that's what they are used to
right but instead instead of having a
fire buffer instead of having something
that wouldn't burn
we had something that was extremely
explosive uh when it came to a spine it
was productive with exactly the wrong
exactly the wrong stuff yeah and so
um you know I I remember
standing at a roadblock that I was
helping to maintain at that point near
the creek and you could just hear like
people's propane tanks exploding and the
the valley was glowing and you know two
towns burning down puts off a lot of
light
um
and yeah looking at their Creek and just
realizing wow this is what we've brought
by allowing these systems to collapse
out allowing that soil to dry up these
novel niches where then we get this
dense vegetation
um you know it has consequences has huge
consequences and so the reverse is true
too with with beavers and fire where you
have a system where beavers are
maintaining a landscape that's wetted
you see wildlife run to that when
there's a fire a lot of folks that work
cattle will see their cattle go to the
beaver Wetlands when there's a fire on
the east side you know of Oregon or so
they've got to be two reasons for that I
would guess
um one the activity of the Beaver is
fire suppressive in nature but two
the choice of beavers to to alter a
particular piece of habitat may be
responsive to it being resilient to fire
because if you because remember the
other ecosystem engineer that's been
operating the same timeline people were
burning we were making making use of
fire yeah right so there was a boundary
between the two ecosystems that's right
that had to be maintained that had to be
maintained and you can imagine let's say
that you had a beaver that was naive
about fire
and it was very good at engineering and
it modified some habitat that was
particularly prone to Fire and the point
is well that's a short-term project too
right because to the extent that the
beaver is dependent on you know trees in
the riparian zone uh surviving then the
point is it made an error yeah building
in a place that had an Achilles heel so
anyway yeah you could uh you could see
both of those processes at work and you
could see
augmentation right whereas again in the
west we have
a plague of eucalyptus trees right I
presume beavers do not utilize
eucalyptus I've never heard of it yeah
yeah although they will go after incense
Cedar which has a pretty
pungent uh it it does seem to be rare
though and they seem to mostly use it
for building things with and not eating
it yeah building with cedar mix
in an aquatic setting right right
totally exactly well the interesting
thing is too in the context of fire if
you have a degraded system that don't
doesn't have beavers
uh maybe it's super incised and so they
can't every time they try to build a dam
it can't persist because the velocity is
just too much it's like a bowling alley
yeah of water every winter and it blows
beaver dams out which is the case with
Bear Creek for example for my from my
Valley
um
and that's usually because we've
straightened it or what have you but
that would happen naturally in some
systems too if something catastrophic
happened and you get this channelization
and
um well then
that's an especially fire prone
situation because beavers can't
maintain that and you do get a fire
that's a stand replacing fire well sand
replacing fires then you have a lot of
accumulated Woody debris that starts
crashing down in that stream
and your velocity barrier is suddenly
not such a thing anymore because you've
got all this roughness and Tangled
burned wood that starts catching the
sediment that comes off the fire because
you know sediment's moving once a fire
fire landscape isn't late yeah it gets
rained on
um fires are a reset for a system that
beavers are hard to find hard to to
utilize to utilize and suddenly you've
got something where every single one of
the hardwoods is bouncing back with
fresh new shoots you've gotten rid of
the Conifer layer that you know beavers
don't really find palatable anyway and
all those are racked up in the Stream
and you've got you've hit reset and now
it's ready for beavers the tragic thing
is of course then what we usually do is
we go clean out every single stick that
falls in the creek because we're worried
about flooding implications and so it
only makes it worse
um oh goodness but the the intelligence
of the system being what it you know
fires could be a good thing for Beaver
too and that they prep it prep a habitat
that's inaccessible to be more
accessible again
yeah that's interesting I I like that
concept of uh of reset and it is a kind
of a hopeful one right even a place that
isn't Beaver hospitable because the
velocity of the water is too high can as
a natural process can find itself within
range of you know Beaver architecture
that's cool we don't have to wait for
Wildfire we could go stick sticks in the
creek you know well I mean people do
yeah you you could you could encourage
the beavers in that way
um and presumably
my guess would be that the Beavers
actually detect the reset that the
consequences of fire might cause beavers
to go into Explorer mode
um because it may be possible that some
piece of habitat that wasn't useful is
now useful
um but presumably they are in Explorer
mode enough just by virtue of producing
Offspring uh yeah and it actually seems
like the adults themselves
um go into Explorer mode every summer so
there's accounts dating back 150 years
of naturalist snow dancing but you know
like where did the Beavers go in July
and August and it does appear that
beavers will go assess the surrounding
landscape and check in and then they
come back and they keep investing or
they don't you know so one of the things
we see happen on the landscape sometimes
is like
you know there's a nearby colony and it
gets trapped off and it's in better
habitat than this other colony while
they go and explore mode that summer
they find out hey those digs are open
yeah and then they jump ship on this one
and they move Downstream
so what happens
then in the context of
some human who is having a disagreement
with Beaver at their driveway Culvert
you know the pipe where the water is
supposed to go through and beavers plug
it and they're like haha you know that
human left one hole in a perfectly good
Dam right
now I've identified that I've fixed the
issue we now have flooding
um
so people get on this treadmill of
trapping beavers right beavers and they
get replaced by and they get replaced by
other beavers in the landscape who have
identified no that's the better habitat
and so you have a population sink you
have a black hole all right right so you
can have just one
person who's just kind of stripping out
beavers depleting land that they are not
actually trying to keep beavers out of
exactly yeah yeah but because that was
the preferred habitat
then you're going to see depletion and
probably because of that Explorer mode
yeah you know and and we've seen this
where
um you know a whole
little sub Watershed will be full of
beavers and then some land ownership
will change and the new landowner is
intolerant and they happen to be at the
best Beaver habitat and over the course
of the year they or two or five they
trap a lot of beavers and suddenly
there's no other beavers around
wow you know oh that's such a terrible
story
yeah I mean it's also encouraging I
guess in that
usually folks don't want to be trapping
beavers right they're on that treadmill
and it's frustrating for them too so
kind of helping folks think through you
know can can the monkeys outsmart the
rodents generally you can or the fish
outsmart the fish right you know it
doesn't quite well
it's confusing yeah but but the promise
in doing that is like if you can
identify those populations things if you
can identify those black holes where
yeah where folks are struggling and you
know they may it's just a pest species
whatever
um it can have profound impacts on the
entire you know square miles of are you
talking about by getting them to rethink
getting rid of the Beavers or it seems
to me that if you could I mean it's a
weird thing to advocate for but if
they're going to be a black hole for
beavers through this process
getting them to reduce the quality of
that habitat that they're trying to keep
beavers out of so that other beavers
don't adopt it would also have that
effect it would yeah it would be
probably very illegal in most areas
really yeah because our wetlands are so
well protected legally
um that you can't purposely degrade a
wetland and that's part of the fear that
people feel when a beaver shows up it's
like
now I'm gonna have this animal that's
going to encumber my property with
additional regulation right you know
quick often before it starts doing stuff
yep
um yeah I get it yeah yeah but yes
that's true if you're if your property
was in a degraded state
um in comparison to other adjacent
properties then you could predict the
Beavers are going to occupy the next
best available habitat and what we often
see is if you have too many population
sinks
then beavers the only beavers you see
are the ones that are living on Rivers
because
Life is Peachy on a river man you can
have a bank Den right you've got all the
willow you could ever eat the water's
deep no need to build a dam yeah right
and
um as long as there's always room they
never hit carrying capacity right like
not all the spots are filled on the
river then no juvenile is ever gonna
have to go make a living higher up in a
stream where you got to build a dam and
life is more work and water is scarce
um and so that you know people will say
well we have enough beavers they're in
all these systems but
we're living in a uh I've heard the term
like functionally extirpated right yeah
and that yes there's beavers but
functionally right they're no longer a
verb so my guess based on what you've
said is that the river beavers are
present but they are not as valuable
that the work that they do is not in a
position to to have this fire
suppressive right they're not managing
water yeah they're not they're cycling
nutrients still sure you know but it's
we selfishly as people looking at this
we need it to be at the point where the
river's so chock-a-block full of beavers
that the young ones are forced to go out
and do real work do some work yeah yeah
right right yeah that's uh interesting
and and uh
quite quite sad really it's interesting
that it's the same animal that can do
this on a river and
um and managing Upland habitat yeah well
and that's cool too right because you
can take a a river beaver and go stick
it up Linda it's like damn it it does
exactly that it does a thing which
actually makes sense if you think about
it because you probably have a
you know a population level phenomenon
where the rivers are the thing that
links all of these disjointed Upland
habitats and so you know I'd be really
interesting to know maybe you do know
what the relationship is between the
river populations and all of these
little uh tributaries in the Hills yeah
no I don't I don't there's been some
genetic studies done and basically it
says
you know beavers are more related in
um watersheds and than they are in the
next Watershed over you know but it
didn't really tell that's not surprising
yeah exactly
um
is anything known about how many
generations a particular you know a
large Dam and Lodge represent how long a
particular lineage of beavers will
manage a particular piece of habitat
well it's kind of like the big whales
right we went killed them all and then
we're looking back at historical records
and we're like that whale was way bigger
than anything we see now how old was it
right no idea you know is that bowhead
whale that they found a 200 year old
Stone Point in yeah they're like okay
well we know they get to 200 yep right
um we're in a similar position with
Beaver because where are the places that
we didn't go trap out beavers and bus
beaver dams there's one spot in the
Boreal forest where there's a beaver dam
you can see from space
that's clearly been there a long time
wow um and it's shifted so much of the
landscape that it's a it's a spot you
can identify
um
but yeah these I the the
life cycle of a beaver dam in a place
where there's a lot of sedimentation
right where the where the water turns
murky in the winter
um is that that will accumulate behind
the Beaver Dam and eventually you'll get
Meadow
yep you know back to it being flat
because of beaver dams yep right but the
water has to go somewhere so it'll be
threaded through or maybe it'll be over
on this side now more than that side and
um beavers will be building additional
dams and so it's this process of
um uplift right and uh yeah creating
land creating land yeah and so yeah
those Cycles are iterative where you'll
have
you know
ghosts of beaver
kingdoms you know buried underneath the
New Meadows that have been formed more
recently right it's um
yeah so so a beaver dam that exists
for a really long time
uh as one Dam I would predict that
there's not a lot of sediment coming in
I guess is you know because otherwise it
would have otherwise we're in Sacramento
yeah okay well there's no reason these
things didn't last a really long time
hundreds of years yeah right or more and
uh again it's going to be compromised by
the fact that we're all we're looking at
modern stuff and we don't necessarily
know what the the pre pre-columbian or
maybe even pre-human uh situation was
yeah and in a beaver dam that's old even
20 years old you can't tell it's a
beaver dam right I mean that's the
that's the great yeah that's right the
classic like oh lattice work of sticks
that only lasts for two or three years
and then it looks like a landscape right
yeah yeah yeah they're funny you have to
identify them by the fact that the water
is behaving in a way differently exactly
yeah exactly
um so what is the largest beaver
body of water that is known oh I don't
know I don't know it's a good question
and that because there's you can measure
that two-way like tallest Beaver Dam
right right and you could measure
laterally out beavers when they when
they so say you've got an in size system
right in size meaning that the creek has
collapsed into this trench yeah and
beavers successfully build a dam there
at first it kind of looks like the
Hoover Dam in a sense I mean it's just
this plug right
um but then quickly if they get out on
the on the valley floor they start
chasing the water with a release usually
pretty low Dam initially yeah and and
they are remarkably Adept at more or
less tracing the topography lines so if
you look at a Beaver Dam from above and
then you were to Overlay a topo line map
yeah sufficient detail that damn you
know every decision that they made in
making that would overlay well with
topography well it makes sense because
water is self-leveling exactly so all
you have to do is make a decision the
next inch over yeah you know right and
so then they'll chase that usually to
the valley edges and then those things
start going up and then some of that
blows out but then they catch it down
lower and so it's back to it being a
process right like yeah the dam itself
um
very quickly if this process is working
you can't point to and say this is the
dam in a simplified system it's really
easy to say well that's the primary Dam
that's the dam that they use to back up
water over there Danning situation these
are auxiliary dams these are just
facilitating habitat right yeah but then
as soon as it actually really starts
working
it's all kind of unclear well I feel
better now that I didn't spot that that
Wetland near uh near Evergreen yeah
suggests that it's more mature and
developed yeah it was definitely it was
definitely a long-standing
um spot pretty pretty nifty
[Music]